drone racing is a new type of sport just
like Formula One or NASCAR vehicles race
against each other at high speeds trying
to avoid one another while weaving
through twists and turns but these are
flying robots cruising around in midair
and they're doing it at speeds of up to
90 miles an hour
drone racing is this new sport it's very
exciting it only emerged about 18 months
ago involves when people take drones and
they put cameras on them and those
cameras give a video feed to goggles to
fly the drones to what we call
first-person view it's like sitting in
the cockpit of the drug we fight the
best pilots we go to the most exciting
venues and we have fantastic robot
racing when you wear video goggles and
you have a camera on the drone and
you're flying it at speed you begin to
get really immersed the way the drone
racing league does it drone racing is
also a brand new type of spectator sport
the viewing experience to the audience
is actually even better than the
experience of the pilots these drones
are bright they're moving quickly
they're loud it's a bit like being at a
NASCAR course but then they have the
added advantage that they can also pull
on the goggles and they can see a fee
off the track we're able to transmit
video feed live in real time we just
want to make sure it's as exciting to
watch as it is the pilot and so for the
audience they can experience any aspect
of the race just by choosing which
viewpoint they want to see it from
forget packed stadiums or even watching
these races in person this sport is all
about immersive at home viewing on TV on
the web or on a VR headset the drone
racing league sees itself not only as a
professional sports league but also as a
video production company so the new
droves of DRL they're made to be in
front of the camera the camera
technology that's used in the drones is
also just at its early its phases and
it's adapted from other industries you
can easily imagine three-dimensional
cameras having two lenses to give both
apply
it's and the audience a 3d view of the
course that's coming act of the next
year is destined to be a big one for the
drone racing league they plan to hold
six races in 2016
across the United States the drones
aren't the only thing the league builds
from scratch they also design new
courses for each event with vertical
hairpin turns tight squeezes and other
surprises every time we go out to race
we can't be in someplace exciting and
this is a new sport that's wrapped in
new technology makes you realize how
close to the future we are so how do you
watch these races the league says it
will make these videos available on
their website but just like any other
sports league they're also pursuing
distribution deals expect to see more of
this immersive emerging sport in the new
year